welcome to this video playing the hot
chick FM Dragic Croatian no no slovakia
I really need to do some some flag flag
testing or something I'm improving but
those especially those white white blue
and red there are so many of those okay
we gotta tell rush French tirage
displaying those is very classical set
up with Bishop b6 and ig2g seven this
was a very popular in the I don't know
for a long time popular for a long time
in the 70s and 80s mostly and it went
out of fashion a bit like players some
sort of lost interest in this line it's
still very solid I mean it's no no real
reason not to play it I'm pretty sure
what I did here wasn't so precise to be
honest
you know it already looks quite
comfortable for black I'm sorry queen
bee three yeah you can take on d4 and
exchange some pieces yeah okay it's an
isolated Paul and stuff you want to
exchange pieces if you play against it
but this has some still am quite
satisfactory exchange 94 94 bit should
be 292 and then continue from there now
this is an optimal you can also i think
what you shouldn't do si maybe he has
some concrete reason yeah we shouldn't
take on b3 the Sun would have helped me
and he didn't he didn't take when she
suddenly makes much more sense he
attacked h2 so I am I secured it yeah
yeah hold still still it should be a
comfortable position for white I
shouldn't be worse the night only two is
hanging and it doesn't really have a
great square yeah there should be three
years old so not a move you want to play
okay let's play rookie one there should
be three years yeah it doesn't help to
to initiate exchanges on d file this is
why I didn't want to play it
yeah Queen at five maybe maybe he wants
to go down
okay Brooke do you one should shouldn't
be bad his pawn this week i mean i'm not
sure maybe maybe he played some
inaccurate move at that at one point he
had feels like i'm i'm in good shape i
can just take it now no real reason not
to take it I just have just have one
that isolated pawn for no particular
compensation I think okay well be sure
to h2 still a move where'd you go yeah
he's also in a pen maybe I should play
King everyone getting out of the check
and keep this pinned alive
I move moving the night now to deform
why not activating it Knight to f3
jonnie2 it is really badly placed I'm
also having this 9 p-5 idea
young yeah well with really good
technical play white should preserve
this action to the end game it's some
stole a bit tricky
the best kind of end game would be a
without any made any heavy pieces
exchanged looks and queens this would be
in fact rather easily winning with three
against two on the queenside he's not
moving this irritates me it's not like
em this is so difficult he's a trouble
of course but not not sure what he's
calculating arrested some connection
issue nope
I had only played him twice before
winning one and one draw yeah he's still
on I'm not quite sure what he's doing
why why is spending so much time or am I
have no i don't think i have a
connection issue no i don't not that's
not clear what is doing well sometimes
it doesn't really relate to the position
and you just have the doorbell ringing
or your your pizza is coming that you
ordered or whatever so um it can be any
reason yeah bit of shamed would be
interesting to see if I could convert
this de spawn and I was expecting him to
move the Queen may be Queen c8 or
something and maybe a six covering the
b5 square it's not so clear this to see
to say how how he should defend because
he basically will we do be worse in any
kind of position but it's a different
levels of being worse and you always
have to choose between very awesome or
effects on time problematic positions
yeah bit of a shame as mentioned would
have liked to continue you have the
compounds to check lasix yeah something
like that and then he needs to try to
defend him maybe queen here and queen to
c7 and try to go here it's not it's not
so so easy for white to win the pawns
are not advanced yet and it's mentioned
I'd like to get rid of the Queen's and
rooks rook endgames also not bad of
course but they are the drawing margin
is notoriously high so you rather want
to
night against Tom Bishop here there was
a bit strange how quickly he got into
trouble around here it really cannot be
a problem what is the computer
suggestion night f5 yeah this is in fact
interesting attacking the night while
I'm not able to move it to a good to
good square and then compress after
rookie one very logical it wants to play
Bishop to c5 yeah yeah this is sometimes
quite quite nice that they're what the
computer moves that are based on on
calculation really fit with the generals
themes like controlling the simple
square something like that it's no
problem for black at all and not 48 I'm
sorry first this move I need to go
somewhere somewhere not too attractive
and then rub dat and this is just
nothing 11 point is that whenever I move
the night black and play d4 for example
check now you can you you're just no
active this piece is better than this
piece and I have no way to win the porn
alright thanks for watching